[Music]  Ladd suits are the rock star of all the  Kizer suits out there we're all used to  those murky shadowy quiet plaids this is  the one that comes bursting on your  closet  [Music]  one of my favorite things about a really  strong plaid suit is that you can wear  it as a suit and where does a sport coat  you can wear it as a pair of pants with  a jean jacket Ladd is loud the  furnishings must be quiet  you put on a pale-blue saw a white shirt  a gray tie and black briefcase you're  ready to go  [Music]  the heritage of the plaid suit is really  legendary the Duke of Windsor wards and  he added color he had a red or he had a  baby blue pull out the color that's in  the plaid and you know really make it  pop  it's not for the faint of heart but it  certainly is something you're gonna want  to grab football  [Music]